volonté politique et une volonté des
deux collectivités locales de créer un
pont comme on l'a dit et feu ce pont là
il va être matérialisée par une
dynamique des jeunes et puis de moins
jeunes qui vont aller partager de
l'expérience le savoir faire et pu
développer des projets sur les deux
territoires donc il s'agit précisément
pour france mon entière qui est un
organisme
d'accompagnement de
l'engagement solidaire et citoyen à
l'international de permettre à des
jeunes de pouvoir concrétiser ce
partenariat
donc c'est un partenariat qui est
fondamental c'est comme la comme l'ont
dit les deux présidents c'est un
partenariat qui va permettre de créer un
pont entre la martinique et le belge et
donc l'envoi de jeunes et de moins
jeunes sur des projets de développement
sous des missions de solidarité
internationale est fondamentale pour
donner un visage humain à la coopération
entre la matinée et le bnd c'est trop
grande à voir les belles de france vers
sur cette opération
oui c'est très important parce que
france volontaires va garantir la
qualité des parcours d'engagement
citoyen à l'international les jeunes ça
veut dire que les jeunes qui vont partir
ils vont être réparées être accompagnés
sur le terrain et à leur tour ils vont
être accompagnés pour un
réinvestissement de l'expérience sur le
territoire de 10 patients et donc c'est
fondamental
la qualité de l'accompagnement des
jeunes et des moins jeunes qui
s'engagent dans le cadre de cette
coopération entre l'espace sud et
l'association des communes de
l'atlantique du littoral au bénin donc
c'est clair que les jeunes qui vont
avoir cette expérience là ce sont les
personnes qui vont promouvoir ce
partenariat qui vont donner un visage
humain à ce partenariat est donc pour
nous c'est fondamental la qualité de
l'accompagnement de tout le processus
d'engagement citoyen à l'international
au bénin